>> So, as we
heard a talk from Bempu
Healthcare yesterday,
their team has this baby
incubator, like a setup,
which helps babies
who are either born
prematurely or who have
been in the ICU
for a day or more.
When they're brought back home,
how can we also give
them a level of
care especially in rural areas?
So, they've developed
this system which can
have a smartphone
tracking the baby,
and they also ask questions
regularly through nurses.
So, we thought of how we can use
AI for such a system and this is,
I'm speaking on behalf
of my team, of course,
people from Bempu
Healthcare represented,
from MSR India we have Jackie,
USC Brian was s team member,
and from Triple IT Delhi,
Angipan Golal, are in the team.
So, our societal problem
is to prevent
neonatal deaths and not all
babies can be kept in ICUs,
so you have to think of what
we can do when they're at
home just when
they're discharged.
These are high-risk babies,
low birth weight, premature.
The current climate is that there
are two solutions available.
They're either ASHA workers
who are supposed to
make home visits,
but it's hard for them to keep
track and they cannot
visit as often.
The second solution
is what Bempu has
proposed which is more like
a sensor- based system.
What we would like to do
is to see how they can
deploy this proposal and
the system to many more patients.
They tell us the problem they
have is that it's not
the government that they
actually have approval
to deploy this
to many more children,
but the problem is
they don't have
the resources because theirs is
a very resource intensive model.
So, they have doctors who
look at these videos,
and they also have
nurses who call twice
every day each of these
parents of babies.
So, we thought one way
AI or machine learning
could help is in
simply predicting risk of
different babies as we
get data from them.
I'll talk about the exact kinds
of data we have.
The second problem we
can also think of is
that it might help in two ways.
One is it can reduce
the manual effort.
So for example, if a nurse has
10 or 20 babies to keep
track of every day,
the nurse may prioritize
who to call and who to
ask more questions and spend
more time with as a triage,
and the second is
it can also help
Bempu Healthcare scale
up their system to
more people and also
look at which signals
are really important.
So, maybe it is that
some parts of the video
are not important,
or maybe some questions
are not important.
So based on this analysis,
they will be able to fine-tune
their system for a low cost.
So, the concrete problem we have
identified is that we would
like to look at all the signals
that we get currently
from Bempu system,
and just model for now as
a simple classification problem,
is the baby at its
current state healthy,
or are they showing
any signs of abnormality,
or extremely, they need some
medical attention right now.
So, these are the three
categories Bempu Healthcare
already has labeled
in their data.
So in our case,
we have already some data
available which
their team is happy to
share after this workshop.
The data consists of 100 patients
on which they have
the system deployed.
They found that out of them,
four were readmitted so they
were really extreme cases,
and 20 required follow-up,
and because they were doing it in
a very manually intensive way,
they were able to track these
patients and do the follow-up.
So, what we are thinking
of is if we have the data
which is demographic and
medical history of the baby,
we have the vital signs data
for some patients,
not all because they
have these sensors,
we have videos, four per day,
which means like four
times the camera
activates and records the video,
and then we have
two phone calls from
nurses which will also
happens twice per day.
So, even though it might
look that we only
have 100 patients,
if you look at
the actual sample size,
these four videos per day for
each baby they have two weeks.
So it's about 70 datapoints
approximately per baby.
So proposed solution
will go in two parts.
One is that we're going to
do an exploratory analysis
first just to see
which kinds of signals
are more predictive,
are correlated with
the bad outcomes,
either an abnormality
or a needs attention.
The second task would be
based on these insights,
you want to build
a classifier to predict
whether a baby is healthy or not.
The idea is that if, and you
want to be conservative,
so you only want to say
a baby's healthy when
it's on the far end
of really healthy.
If you find any sign
of abnormality,
we actually want to
raise it and then
we'll have a nurse or
a doctor take it from there.
Finally, of course, it also
can help Bempu later on to
fine-tune their product
to only collect
a certain set of
data and not all.
These are some examples of
images that they have collected,
and we would like
to, essentially,
let's say if this baby is
healthier than this baby,
then you want to check that
and be able to use video.
So, the estimated impact.
This is just a
calculation that we
did among our team members.
We have found that four babies
out of the 100 that
hadn't trial required
readmission.
So what it means
is that as we get
more and more babies
in the systems,
then nurses could prioritize,
and therefore get
more people having
a chance to be treated and
readmitted to hospitals.
It will also help us to think
of how we can also enable
the ASHA workers who are
not a part of this system,
but maybe that
learnings that we have
of either phone calls
or some kinds of
sensors could also be used
when ASHA workers
do their visits.
Ethical concerns.
I think there are
two ethical concerns
that we discussed.
So, the first is if
our detector is raising a lot
of alarms for no reason,
parents might get worried and
get anxious for no reason.
The other more
serious one is that
if our detector makes mistakes,
parents might feel everything is
fine whereas their baby
might be having
a medical problem.
Our current solution with this
is to be as conservative
as possible.
So always, it's better to
raise false alarms than not,
in our case at least, we think,
but this is something we
have to talk to doctors
and Bempu team to figure
this straight off.
The other two are, I think,
a common concern with using data,
so we would want to protect
patient information.
So I think, we'll
try to see if we can
anonymize all the data and
especially the videos,
and also how patient
consent which Bempus I
think already has for doing
research with this data.
One concern, although it's
not an ethical concern,
I think it's more
of a data concern,
is that not all of
the parents comply,
so we won't have data
for all of these babies
on all times but I
think that's also
an interesting technical
challenge to look at.
So our concrete next steps.
Luckily, we are in a position
where we can access
the data and the Bempu team
has kindly accepted to share it.
Our plan is in
the next two months,
we'll do exploratory
analysis to find
the key signals that really
matter in terms of
the outcomes we have,
and then as a part of
that same process in
the next four to six months,
we would want to deploy
a classifier that can just
look at these sensors and help
nurses make
prioritized decisions.
Beyond that, I think our goal is
that it actually gets
integrated into what
Bempu is doing and we do
trials with this technology.
That's it. Thank you.
>> The baby classification,
is this for the baby or
the whole time or is it,
at this point in time
this baby does not look
healthy or healthy,
so it's sort of much more
period by time period.
>> Yes, it is the time period
by time period classification.
In fact, I think what
we'll actually do is
to look at only the change
in each baby.
So, at any point of
time, let's say time t,
we look at the baby's signals and
video at time t minus
1 and we try to see
how much this change
corresponds to a healthy
versus a abnormality.
But really, I think
we want to do it at
the same time so that
nurses can respond.
>> Very quick question while
the next group sets up.
>> If you have many the cases where
the babies actually [inaudible]
>> Yes. I think
that's a good point.
So, as I said, we have to
strike the right balance
but I think the other side
is way more worse.
So we took the conservative side.
But hopefully, I think
our algorithms will
be able to detect with
some accuracy that this
trade-off is little reduced.